and here we go second meeting this season Panthers
first win of the year was in New Jersey way back
in October and here comes carder breaking in
giving to kachuck out in front it's Bennett and
it hit the post that's how he scored the other
out against LA s pett off the rush anan's had
about four post or cross bars in that win in
La against La dah's a big goal tender so the
Panthers will look to get those pucks on rebounds
quickly to the net and take advantage but the
Devils may have an odd man Rush here brat leads
the three on two drop pass and the shot goes high
from tley sent on goal deflected saved by moski
Lazar Moves In for the Devils off the [Applause]
wing picked up now by nemit the young defenseman
H sends it in front score deflect Lo it in Tierney
was out in front the Devils strike first early
on three goals in the first period so far make
it four now but it never deters the Panthers they
just keep on coming and luckwood is stopped by
Daws Panthers working free it's forsling with a
quick shot that one hit the post two posts early
by the Panthers forsling sends it wide great jump
on this shift after the Jersey goal it's held in
again gajic sent it to the net kicked out quick
shifts by the Panthers and they're successful
at getting the fresh players on the ice while
the Puck's in the devil Zone coaches love that
Heir gets through the neutral zone save by bosski
Sam Bennett Pan's got an excellent goal tending
as well from Anthony stolar and defensively
they're one of the top three teams in the
league doing a great job in front of both FES
as well here's a shot bosski to save scr out in
front maybe one day down the road but he's too
busy trying to win a Stanley Cup Marino with
a shot save bosski and it's up and out of play
Chuck and Reinhardt both on five game goal streaks
they've scored in every game in 2024 last game
they both hooked up Chu tied it late Reinhardt
won it an overtime there's MOSI with a save on
Holtz the give to barov [Applause] he'll turn and
send it in behind the net bounces to the corner
Reinhardt looking to find it along the wall now
barov shot is stopped oh Alexander barov let that
rip Heckman Larson sends it towards the net wide
kulakov played it around cut off by Smith and now
the devils look to break it out it's McLoud moving
in with Bratt McLoud on the backand kicked out by
Sergey moski there's the the devils in transition
again one- nothing Devils Alexander Holtz 350
into the game here's dos he'll come out and handle
it now git's shot is gloved but it's
clear to the panther [Applause] line
and now Sam Reinhardt gives to
Rodriguez with a shot blocker
save barov threw a pretty good hit
there at brat as he moved that puck
ahead for Tyler T Foley weaves
his way to the line cut off by
Rodriguez no penalties yet in this game it's a
it's a no hitter so far that'll change at some
point kachuck taken back by Brat trying to get
in front now McLoud shoots and he scores it snuck
through and the Devils have a two nothing lead
Michael McLoud is 11th of the year here's Dimitri
kulakov loses his man there right out in front
and then the followup and Sergey boski is not very
happy he thought that there was a little bit of
goal tending interference there you see and Hughes
trying to clear barov on him Hughes tries again
and this time he gets it out to Center picked up
by Dawson merer into the slot Mercer with a Chance
save B rovski [Applause] Bo McLoud is really come
on for the Devils 11th goal of the Season playing
up with Hughes out normally a fourth line Center
that puck out of play Lockwood speeding it after
the puck gets there here's will Lockwood circling
in behind out towards the front of the net gives
Jen eblad with a shot knocked down in front
Bastion got a stick on that it's still free down
at the goal line e flad chops it up high Hughes
trying to keep in couldn't do it Bennett to Center
Bastion is all over him they both go [Applause]
down here's Daws playing it the Chuck forces a
turnover final seconds it's for Hy in front e Lon
is stopped at the buzzer oh they came close right
there yeah with time running out in the first
period barov controls try to get it to Rodriguez
off his skates Here Comes heer one-on-one against
monou heer looking for a hall of the shot he
scores it's a 3 nothing New Jersey lead oh for
the love of salmon sandwiches and rubber boots
when things go bad they go bad it's a good two
on two good back pressure pressure by the Panthers
they've got some numbers there but somehow holla
just pulls up and yeah he just sweeps it towards
the goal and just handcuffs Sergey boski it it's
kind of Reinhardt to finish off the play faceof
Win it's forsling with a big blast does the same
he's looking for the rebound it's still loose
Reinhardt is stopped now eblad picks it up made
it 3 nothing here in the second Rodriguez to the
point for forsling eblad gets it towards the net
save Rebound in front it's barov and he's stopped
oh what a chance forsling fires that one to
flex that plad for kachuck leads Bennett in
Bennett in front for hay shoot stopped again
oh Daws with a save there now kachuck again
sweeps it out in front Veri turns and fires
blocked away barov in front the shot stopped by
Daw he made the save on Reinhardt Monto shot in
front there's the chance of Sam Reinhardt
does it again make it six in a row with a
power play goal and the cats are alive he is
just Unstoppable not a defense in the league
can stop this Panthers up top patient right
to kachuck and between the legs to Reinhardt
that freezes the defense nothing they can do
about that and Reinhardt gets his 31st of the
season that's a fole he was looking to go oh
that hit the referee up high and the Panthers
may get a chance out of it Nicholas shoots
FL save rebound of the blue paint poked that
and Daw makes the stop right at the goal line
Montour fires stopped Montour again cross ice
carder hay gives to Reinhardt Reinhardt looks and
shoots it's off the post again I don't believe it
and then Reinhardt is stopped by Daws on the
follow Mercer in front for Tierney blocked by
barkov again another shot towards the empty
net is wide Tierney fans on the attempt and
then another Block in front barov has saved that
goal a few times with his clock is winding down
on the Panthers and finally Marina stuffs
it in to make it four to one yeah Panthers
just couldn't get control of that puck it
kept bouncing back onto the Stick Of The
Devils when they had all six of those players
there's the first block by barkov and then it
comes over and watch there's m in the Around
the Net area as well was amazing in nine but
it ends tonight as the Devils come to town
and score the 4-1 victory over the Panthers